éliminé roi way par tous les moyens
c'est le ressenti de la chine concernant
l'opposition américaine à
l'implémentation du réseau 5g de
l'entreprise chinoise
ce géant de la technologie a pour
ambition d'installer son réseau au
brésil le gouvernement de donald trump
s'y opposent fermement
face à cela les autorités chinoises
évoque un acte hégémonique flagrant
monsieur pompéo et certains hommes
politiques américains ont fait pression
à plusieurs reprises sur d'autres pays
ont mis en avant la coopération 5g
d'autres pays et ont ouvertement contre
1 des nations à obéir à la volonté des
états unis il s'agit d'un acte
hégémonique flagrant lorsque des
entreprises d'autres pays devienne
dominante
la classe politique américaine fabrique
des excuses et utilise le pouvoir de
l'état pour les éliminer par tous les
moyens
considéré comme le leader mondial de la
5g
or huawei inquiète du côté de washington
on redoute des risques en termes de
cyber sécurité et l'administration trump
n'hésite pas à faire du chantage aux
pays qui accepterait l'implantation du
réseau 5g de roy way
je ne parlerai pas de représailles mais
de conséquences quand vous investissez
vous regardez où vous pouvez le faire
n'importe quand le gouvernement chinois
peut demander à huawei de lui
communiquer des informations
notre économie est basée sur les
services la plus grande exportation des
états unis c'est la propriété
intellectuelle nous devons la protéger
le brésil devait lancer cette année son
appel d'offres pour la 5g échéance
repoussée à l'année prochaine en raison
de la crise du coronavirus de son côté
le royaume uni a annoncé au milieu du
mois vouloir éviter les équipements de
roy way en mentionnant un risque réel
pour la sécurité des données
personnelles